[Musique]
on saura tout ce nouveau débat sur tv 78
et radio sensations dans le cadre du
second tour des élections municipales
2020 le dimanche 28 juin prochain les
électeurs sont appelés aux urnes pour le
second tour un scrutin reporté suite à
la crise sanitaire du coronavirus un
contexte qui nous oblige aussi à
enregistrer cette émission dans des
conditions particulières les candidats
seront connectés à distance et ce soir
direction la verrière trois listes sont
maintenus après le premier tour le 15
mars dernier dans l'ordre communiqués
par la préfecture des yvelines jean yves
blais tête de liste divers gauche
ensemble la verrière citoyenne soutenue
par europe ecologie les verts
nelly duthu vous mener la liste de
gauche la verrière en commun et nicolas
dainville tête de liste divers droite
une nouvelle dynamique pour la verrière
bonsoir à tous
alors je rappelle que le temps de parole
sera chronométrée afin d'assurer
l'équité entre chacun d'entre vous avant
de commencer je vous propose de regarder
ce reportage qui revient sur les
résultats du premier tour et sur les
principaux enjeux de ce scrutin regard
dur lors du premier tour des élections
municipales 2020 le 15 mars dernier
nelly duthu est arrivé en première
position
la maire sortante est suivi de près par
le conseiller municipal d'opposition
nicolas dainville en troisième position
jean-yves blé ancien premier adjoint et
membre d'un groupe au sein de la
majorité sortante
ces trois listes ont maintenu leur
candidature pour le second tour le 28
juin prochain
la verrière est une commune historique
de la ville nouvelle de saint quentin en
yvelines avec plus de 6000 habitants une
ville touchée par des problématiques
sociales un taux de chômage de 16 % le
taux de pauvreté atteint près de 24%
l'insertion et l'emploi des sujets
d'autant plus important après la crise
sanitaire du coc vie de 10,9 et le choc
économique des thématiques en lien aussi
avec l'éducation et la scolarité dès le
plus jeune âge
la lutte contre l'incivilité et la
relation entre les forces de sécurité
les quartiers populaires un sujet prise
en compte par les candidats la verrière
touchés par le phénomène de désert
médical le manque de médecins et de
professionnels de santé sur la commune
pose des difficultés d'accès aux soins
enjeu crucial par rapport à la pandémie
du coronavirus des projets d'aménagement
sur la ville d'abord la rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'est
tant ce sujet qui divise d'un côté une
rénovation sur les bâtiments existants
de l'autre une destruction
reconstruction partielle de certains
immeubles de projets qui peuvent
bénéficier des fonds de l' agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine autres
quartiers de la verrière orly parc
concerné par plusieurs projets
d'aménagement
autre projet d'urbanisation d'envergure
intercommunale mené conjointement avec
saint quentin en yvelines
le projet urbain gare bécane 1800
logements une zone d'activité économique
et un paul de transport multimodal
juste à côté le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit un enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront ainsi relier pour commencer ce
débat une première question pourquoi
avez vous décidé de maintenir votre
candidature et comment avez vous adaptez
votre programme par rapport à la
situation que nous connaissons le
contexte de la crise du corps d'un virus
et du choc économique qui s'en suit en
suivant l'ordre donné par les services
de l'état on va commencer avec vous jean
yves blé je rappelle que vous êtes
premier adjoint de la maire sortante en
cours de mandat vous avez créé un groupe
au sein de la majorité
et vous êtes arrivé en troisième
position au premier tour comme on vient
de le voir dans ce sujet alors comment
déjà avez vous adapté notre programme à
la situation et pouvez vous nous dire
pourquoi aussi vous est maintenue pour
ce second tour
alors adapter notre programme à la
situation si vous voulez d'abord bonsoir
à tous
si vous voulez il est déjà adapté
programme que la question médicale
déposer des dix points également
dans cette perspective on a décidé de
travailler avec la mgen et puis avec
comment l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines pour un rapprochement et
essayer de faire venir des médecins sur
sur la commune
on a envisagé dans notre programme une
mutuelle pour tous 1
donc dans ce chemin là on en est déjà
par rapport à ce qui nous est arrivé
ces deux mois de confinement qui n'était
pas du tout annoncé il pas prévu on
était déjà dedans donc la question
médicale elle est posée la question
aussi des services publics concernant
les soins elle est posée a également
déposé également depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant 1 parlant sont des
gouvernements qui se sont attelés à
démanteler le service public dans ce
domaine là on voit bien que les deux
mois de confinement ont démontré la
nécessité de ce service public
moi j'ai des colistiers qu'on
travaillait dans ce milieu là et qui ont
été à la peine
vraiment donc il ya une urgence à
regarder notre système de santé et à y
faire et faire attention et celle est
fermé ses pouvoirs publics et l'état ne
arrête de vouloir démanteler ses
services le service des services à la
population sont importants et les
services publics en général c'est
important merci vous atteignez déjà une
minute trente de temps de parole on va
poursuivre justement cette question de
la santé oms va forcément l'aborder 1
par rapport notamment à la solidarité
est question de l'accès aux soins des
habitants de la verrière nelly duthu
vous êtes maire sortante
je rappelle que vous avez été élu maire
en 2016 suite à la démission d'alain âge
alors pouvez vous nous dire pourquoi
vous avez maintenu votre candidature
pour ce second tour
et comment vous avez aussi adapter votre
programme vos propositions par rapport à
la crise sanitaire que nous avons
traversée pourquoi est-ce que je garde
quand tu gardé ma candidature je pense
que on a fait un grand travail pendant
quatre ans sur 7 sur cette ville
là on a proposé avec une nouvelle équipe
un projet de six ans qui nous a valu 40%
de
l'approbation des électeurs je crois
qu'on est les électeurs nous ont montré
qu'ils étaient prêts à nous suivre sur
ce projet donc je ne vois pas je
n'abandonnerai maintenant au contraire
et du coup est-ce que vous avez adapté
votre programme la situation actuelle
alors adapté
on va voir pour l'instant je voudrais
par rapport à cette situation justement
refaire un petit pas en arrière
ça fait un an et demi voire deux ans que
les le personnel de santé dit alerte
pour que nos hôpitaux soient soient
mieux mieux gérer et être plus de moyens
pour travailler on a vu dans ce qu vide
les dégâts que peuvent faire un une
gestion comptable de la santé
ça on le savait je n'en suis pas
surprise et je pense que la plupart des
français non plus et la plupart des
verrières moi non plus c'est forcément
pris en compte dans le projet qu'on a
mis en place même s'il faut renforcer
peut-être quelques quelques oppositions
ce qui me concerne en tant qu en tant
que maire ce qu'ils vont en ce qui vous
concerne c'est surtout le nombre de
médecins qui qui assure la commune alors
oui bien sûr que sur vous savez bien
enfin tout le monde le sait le désert
médical et pas à verrières - il est aidé
national voire voire beaucoup plus quand
il ya pas de médecin c'est compliqué
d'en mettre
par contre on se bat depuis plusieurs
années maintenant puisque jean yves le
j'arrive les le rappelait on a d'abord
travaillé avec à au temps où il était
encore dans la majorité on a travaillé
avec sur un système de santé avec la
mgen qui lie jeunes s'était beaucoup
impliqué à l'époque qui n'a pas qui n'a
pas réussi à voir le jour pour diverses
raisons nous aujourd'hui au projet de
prolongement mais nous on propose
aujourd'hui de travailler sur un centre
de santé communal qui pourrait à mon
avis aider à trouver les médecins en
février j'avais proposé juste en février
j'avais proposé la création d'un poste
de médecin communal à qui est qui n'a
pas été suivi par mais j'avais flemyng
nicholas dainville aujourd'hui ça fait
partie de l'un des axes principaux de
mon projet merci madame dit vous avez
pris beaucoup d'avancé
messieurs d'un monsieur dainville vous
êtes au conseil municipal d'opposition
depuis 2014 vous avez été aussi vous
êtes toujours un conseiller
départemental
vous êtes arrivé en deuxième position au
premier tour derrière nelly duthu alors
même question pourquoi maintenir votre
candidature et avez vous adaptez votre
programme à la situation actuelle mais
écoutez bonjour à tous effectivement on
est à 55 voix seulement derrière la
maire sortante
donc on a bien évidemment maintenu notre
candidature pour essayer d'apporter du
sang neuf une autre vision dans notre
commune de la verrière et puis essayer
de faire des belles choses pour pour
cette ville ensuite sur le co vie de 19
on a déjà dû je pense que c'est le cas
tout autour d'eux de la table de
répondre à la crise en tant qu'élu local
pour ma part en tant qu on s'y
départementale j'essaie d'être efficace
et réactif
avec la livraison de masque en tissu
avec la livraison de gel hydroalcoolique
voilà on a essayé d'apporter des
réponses concrètes pour protéger au
maximum les habitants c'était la
première phase de l'adaptation de notre
comportement dans cette crise inédite
et puis dans notre
notre programme je pense qu'il ya un
point qui est devenu encore plus
important c'est l'éducation c'est vrai
que les outils innovants permettent la
continuité pédagogique dans l'école et à
l'extérieur de l'école beaucoup de
communes ont pris ce virage pédagogique
depuis bien longtemps et je pense que
c'est important qu'on continue dans
cette danse est lancé j'ajouterai un
deuxième point sur le développement
durable
je pense que cette crise nous rappelle à
quel point l'environnement et est
important qu'il faut en prendre soin et
donc non défend notamment un projet de
forêt des enfants pour sensibiliser à la
biodiversité dans le nouveau quartier
des bécanes chaque enfant pourra planter
mille arbres comme ça se fait plaisir
while en cours et puis dernier point
avant de terminer mon propos c'est sur
la question des médecins c'est vrai
qu'on a une désertification médicale qui
touche la france entière mais à la
verrière en particulier le mesnil dans
notre commune voisine on aura bientôt 0
médecin pour près de 15000 habitants
les pharmaciens que j'ai pu voir encore
récemment s'en inquiètent fortement nous
regrette que la maire sortante n'est pas
réussi à maintenir nos médecins sur
place on se bat saut deux projets le
partenariat avec la mgen et une maison
de santé en lien avec nos partenaires
notamment saint quentin en yvelines pour
baisser au maximum les loyers et attirer
des médecins être attractive pour les
personnels soignants
merci nicolas dainville pour ce premier
tour de table même si vous êtes dans le
plateau on va voir un peu les rapidement
les chronos pour faire un point
donc on voit que nelly duthu vous avez
beaucoup d'avancé comme je voulais
préciser nicolas doze et 2 minutes 20 et
monsieur blé vous êtes à une 49
on aura le temps de façon de
rééquilibrer des temps de parole on va
commencer avec la première thématique la
solidarité à une thématique assez large
la thématique de solidarité parce que il
ya un taux de chômage de 16 % à la
verrière on a un taux de pauvreté qui
atteint 24% alors c'est un sujet assez
large ça peut toucher l'accès aux soins
ça peut toucher l'emploi ça peut toucher
l'insertion sociale en plus on est dans
une crise sanitaire in trees
économique qui va peut-être précariser
encore plus certaines familles comment
comptez vous participer justement au
soutien à soutenir les familles des plus
précaires à la verrière on va commencer
avec vous monsieur blé mais écoutez on a
durant le confinement nous on n'est pas
aussi resté inactif puisque policière
madani de l'eau a mis en place une
collecte de manière à ramasser un peu un
peu des deux financière pour aider les
plus démunis
donc on était actif durant durant ce
temps là aussi mais on l'a pas où la
famille sur sur nos réseaux sociaux
comme ça puisqu'on a pensé qu' étant
dans une période un peu particulière de
confinement qu'il fallait mettre entre
parenthèses notre campagne municipale
sur la question de la solidarité on ça
commence aussi avec les aînés et là on a
quelques pistes
on veut créer une dynamique avec eux un
réseau de papis et de mamies qui
viendrait aider nos plus jeunes à sur un
certain nombre de compétences qu'ils ont
à les accompagner dans danser dans ses
compétences la bon cela peut-être à des
choses pratiques de la menuiserie du
bricolage des comptes de la lecture de
l'aide de voir des choses comme ça sur
la question de l'école on n'a pas
attendu
monsieur dainville pour faire la
question du numérique une question
importante du ce qu'on le traite depuis
presque 20 ans maintenant sur notre
commune on a commencé il ya très
longtemps on a développé cet outil on
s'est inscrit dans le programme proposé
par l'agglomération communauté
d'agglomération parce que ça nous
semblait nécessaire et important donc là
dessus on n'est pas en dehors des clous
1 mais il ya encore beaucoup passeur sur
la question
ensuite des moyen qu'ont trouvé encore
aller chercher et notamment dans la
question de l'accompagnement à l'emploi
je vous avais dit la dernière fois quand
on s'était vus en plateau et qu'on avait
mené le débat qu'il y avait déjà les
outils sur le territoire et qu'il
fallait s'appuyer sur ces outils sur
l'emploi dans un sous les temps on
abordera préciserait peut-être après on
va aborder la question de l'emploi
justement juste sur la question minutes
monsieur blé juste à pour que conserver
un peu de temps parle et comme ça on va
aborder aussi l'emploi
monsieur dainville justement sur la
solidarité comment on lutte contre
l'exclusion sociale et la précarité
sociale à la verrière surtout dans le
contexte qu'on connaît
écoutez cette exclusion sociale elle
touche toutes les classes d'âge je pense
que vis-à-vis de nos seniors il faut
multiplier les actions alors destination
voilà des conférences des voyages des
formations notamment le visage d'une
nouvelle technologie
il ya pas mal de choses à faire qui sont
pas coûteuse et qui peuvent vraiment
permettre d'améliorer la qualité de vie
de nos seniors je pense aussi aux
services à la personne au maintien à
domicile avec le portage des repas qui
se fait déjà mais que peut intensifier
la téléassistance et puis sur l'emploi
c'est il ya une autre forme d'exclusion
c'est l'exclusion de ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi n'ont pas de salaire et là on
on parlera sûrement des actions très
importantes il ya certes des outils me
doubler il existe et tant mieux
je pense qu'il ya quand même quelques
trous dans la raquette encore
malheureusement qu'on pourrait corriger
moi je crois beaucoup en la province qui
n'existe pas encore qui est du manteau
en queues des salariés saint quentinois
de nos grandes entreprises et de nos pme
côte et jeunes vers hyérois leur ouvrent
leurs réseaux leur ouvre des
perspectives
les aide dans leur rédaction de cv de
deux lettres de candidature bref le mans
courard c'est pour moi quelque chose de
sacré neigera ajouté un deuxième point
c'est on en a déjà parlé lors du dernier
bye d'école de commerce dans la geria on
arrose paraître lorsqu'un fan harbaoui
attrape pour transmettre aux jeunes
motivés les codes de l'entreprise
on abordera la question de l'emploi
vraiment après jouer d'abord abordé
justement cette question de solidarité
vous allez parler justement des
d'eysines et mais nelly du tüv houle
votre priorité dans votre programme
c'est le cas aussi pour jean-yves
denicolas dame aimait ce que vous
affichez madame duthu c'est la jeunesse
la jeunesse et la solidarité envers les
familles des plus précaires notamment
dans l'est à travers l'éducation
est-ce que vous pouvez nous précise et
justement les points de programme par
rapport à cette solidarité est ce que
vous prévoyez justement pour lutter
contre la précarité pour les habitants
de la verrière oui je suis juste une
petite précision tout à l'heure on va
pas se battre sur sur le nombre de
masques que chacun a distribué etc
on a tous on a tous fait ce qu'il
fallait faire c'est à dire protéger
l'eau les verrières moi à la place qu'on
arrête moi en tant que maire monsieur
nicolas en tant que conseil
départemental et monsieur blé en tant
que groupe et que l'on peut liste aux
opposants
chacun fait son travail je crois que
c'est très bien comme ça et c'est
l'intérêt des derniers rois ensuite sur
la jeunesse oui oui ça reste ma priorité
on a encore beaucoup de jeunes qui
sortent de l'école de 100 formations
réellement qui ne trouvent pas de
travail que la difficulté de trouver des
lieux d'apprentissage également donc là
on a décidé de dans le projet de de
créer un poste qui permettent la liaison
entre ces jeunes qui cherchent un emploi
ou un stage ou une formation et les
entreprises du territoire pour les
accompagner justement est peut-être
mieux faire connaître ce que nos jeunes
sont capables de faire d'une part vous
allez reprendre un peu d'avancé sachant
que je vais poser la question vous allez
apprendre beaucoup d' avance donc je
vous coupe à ce que vous abordez tous la
question de l'emploi on va tout va en
parler tout de suite et je vous pose la
question dans ce cas comme ça on aborde
la question tout de suite juste un point
sur le temps en fait pour nicolas david
vous êtes à trois minutes 53 monsieur
blé vous êtes à 4 minutes 05 et madame
du tout vous êtes à 4 minutes 15 on a
rééquilibré le temps de parole donc sur
l'emploi
vos propositions sur l'emploi on va
peut-être commencer avec monsieur
dainville sur l'emploi dont vous avez
parlé d' école de commerce vous avez
parlé du mentorat vous êtes aussitôt mon
conseiller départemental il ya notamment
l' agence départementale activity ya
plein de synergies finalement à créer
entre les collectivités avec
l'intercommunalité bien évidemment c'est
pour ça que je je je je m'oppose à la
proposition de madame duthu de créer un
poste supplémentaire pour moi la
compétence de l'emploi elle à saint
quentin en yvelines
ça veut pas dire que la mairie ne doit
rien faire bien au contraire
mais la mairie son rôle est de mobiliser
au maximum les moyens mis en place par
notre agglomération pour les mettre à
destination de nos jeunes virois et de
non moins jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
c'est pour moi la mission principale
petit exemple et j'en terminerai là on a
un événement qui s'appelle en piste pour
l'emploi qui a organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines c'est un événement
une fois par an cinq mille offres
d'emploi c'est assez extraordinaire
il faudrait que la verrière face comme
d'autres communes par exemple le magny
les hameaux mettre en place
les moyens de transport pour emmener ses
jeunes cet événement et surtout mettre
en place tout un tas de dispositifs pour
entraîner ses jeunes les préparer pour
ne pas qu'ils soient qu'ils arrivent à
cet événement sans être coaché au
maximum avec des cv avec un bagage
suffisant pour ne pas perdre leur temps
et je terminerai aussi sur un point moi
qui me marquent beaucoup ces derniers
temps c'est qu'on a l'impression d'une
jeunesse à la verrière laissé à
l'abandon
on a beaucoup de jeunes qui dans nos
quartiers n'ont pas assez de d'activité
n'ont pas essayé d'animation ils sont en
demande d'animations de pas être livrés
à eux mêmes je pense qu'il ya aussi au
niveau de l'animation chose à faire
quand je parle de l'école de commerce de
la verrière s'est pas uniquement un
aspect commercial c'est un aspect
culturel emmener nos jeunes en dehors de
la commune leur faire découvrir le
patrimoine extraordinaire des yvelines
et puis de l'ile-de-france sortir nos
jeunes leur proposer aussi de partir de
la commune de voir ce qui existe
ailleurs de voir des rencontres qu'on
met en avant nos talents pour créer des
vocations
tout ça c'est un ensemble mais c'est
pour moi une des priorités principales
de notre bras avant de donner la parole
à jean yves des je vais laisser madame
du tu répondes par rapport au fait que
nicolas david ne défendent pas lent
l'embauchent finalement d'un employé de
mairie pour s'occuper de cette question
là où se fait déjà à saint quentin en
yvelines il ya déjà alors va laisser
répondu tu on va laisser répondre oui
bien sûr que la compétence emploi est à
l'agglomération
ceci dit tout le monde peu trop
remarquer que ça suffit pas le nombre
d'emplois compte deux jeunes qu'on a
sans emploi parle tout seul je veux dire
donc il faut plus que ça il faut amener
plus de travail
tu te portes de proposition et monsieur
dainville d'y emmener les jeunes à 50 à
tout ce qui serait oui bah il faut
quelqu'un pour le faire donc c'est bien
ce quelqu'un là qu'on veut employer
qu'on veut
pour créer cette synergie entre les
jeunes et le bassin d'emploi ça se fait
mais on voit bien que les jeux les jeux
ne lui jette la pierre à personne c'est
difficile pour tout le monde mais on
voit bien que les partenaires
aujourd'hui font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
mais ça ne suffit pas donc chacun à sa
place pour faire mettre une pierre à
l'édifice et je pense que notre façon de
mettre la pierre à l'édifice c'est
d'avoir ce justement cette personne qui
va aider aussi bien sur le territoire
que su ramener les jeunes sur le
territoire de saint quentin en entier
pas que sur la verrière
mais c'est pas la seule solution que je
préconise je vais peut-être une autre
solution ou une proposition avant que
jean yves lainé mettre ses propos de
monsieur david parler des jeunes en
errance
sauf peut-être que vous savez pas tout
sur le territoire peut-être que vous
n'êtes pas allé partout parce que des
actions sur la jeunesse il y en a tous
les jours et à tel point que j'ai encore
reçu trois groupes de jeunes qui veulent
faire leur associer leur association on
va le faire on va les aider on va les
accompagner
ils ont fait partie justement parlez de
solidarité alors c'est peut-être un peu
c'était tout à l'heure mais ils ont fait
partie largement de ceux qui ont mené
des actions solidaires pendant pendant
ce qu vide et on sous le tag nages
messieurs je vous laisse répondre après
peut-être la régie de quartier on
développera peut-être après j'ai que
j'en ai fait une proposition vous avez à
peu près de deux minutes de retard par
rapport aux autres candidats
vos propositions vous sur l'emploi
me concernant et concernant de notre
équipe mais écoutez moi je suis content
de constater que monsieur david me
rejoins sur la question des partenaires
qui existe sur terrain qu'il faut faire
bouger en effet c'est je crois qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un lien qui s'opère
entre les collectivités particulièrement
la nôtre 1 pour ce qui concerne le la
verrière avec ses partenaires
l'idée jeu clie
un interlocuteur de la ville privilégiée
avec ses structures me semble plutôt
intéressant et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
mette en effet quelqu'un qui fasse ce
travail là de lien avec les structures
parce que les structures existent les
moyens il existe on parlait de tutorat
tout à l'heure mais ces deux villes
parlent de tutorat par exemple à la
mission locale
le tutorat existe depuis longtemps le
parrainage existe depuis longtemps il y
à des dispositifs d aide
d'accompagnement puis via par exemple la
garantie jeunes si vous voulez bien le
plan régional d'insertion pour la
jeunesse qui est une structure
intercommunale et qui travaille de
manière à donner et accompagner les
jeunes les plus en difficulté donc les
les outils elles sont là là là où le bât
blesse en quelque sorte c'est ce rapport
entre la collectivité et les structures
et le rôle des élus souvent et souvent
on a constaté qu'il n'existait pas quand
bien même on le pouvait la structure
pouvait relancer la collectivité quelle
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs il n'ya pas ce
lien qui s'opère et c'est dommageable ça
finalement
parce que ça ne permet pas aux
collectivités de voir le travail que
font ces structures là et l'importance
qu'elles ont à rayonner et à faire
travailler
celle ci j'ajouterai que dans l'est sur
le territoire il existe des médiateurs
blank soit il ya des gens qui se
déplacent au sein des communes notamment
celles qui sont en en politique de la
ville pour aller chercher ces jeunes
pour aller discuter avec eux pour les
amener vers des structures qui vont les
aider à avancer dans leur projet
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
donc les structures elles sont là elles
sont là ce qui manque c'est ce lien et
le lien il faut le créer
il faut le mettre en oeuvre et il faut
décider au sein de la collectivité qui
va faire ce lien à la fois avec les
techniciens mais aussi avec les conseils
d'administration pour discuter pour voir
là où il ya des des troupes comme dans
la raquette comme le disait monsieur
d'un vie comme en bouche les trous de
cette raquette et comme on fait avancer
après sur la question du développement
économique confirmée
pro aux lancers choisis et gardés
caniveau parce que dans ce projet là on
y lit et il est pensé aussi de
l'investissement pour de l'accueil
d'entreprises de commerces mais aussi de
petites entreprises et donc ça aussi
c'est une dynamique importante il faut
prendre dans son ensemble de manière à
relancer sur notre territoire et sur
notre commune quelque chose qui
permettra aux jeunes éventuellement de
d'aller travailler de pouvoir trouver du
travail
alors justement on va faire le lien avec
une des propositions de madame du tube
qui veut créer une régie municipale
finalement la mairie créés directement
les emplois alors que jean yves lé là ce
que ce dont vous parlez c'est que le
développement économique doit pousser à
faire venir des entreprises sur le
territoire de la verrière
je suppose que c'est aussi l'idée de ces
deux nicolas d'un villes de
l'agglomération
c'est aussi la compétence de
l'agglomération et la compétence de
l'agglomération c'est comment on
travaille avec l'agglomération pour ça
mais ça le rôle des élus aussi un
monsieur
on est bien d'accord je savais c'est
madame du sud de bloquer des projets il
faut que les bleus
il avoua long mais c'est moi on va juste
laisser madame habitude d'évoluer aussi
on vous parlait tous en même temps vous
entend pas et on va aller juste de
laisser développer là l'idée de la régie
municipale à propositions de même du tue
pour ensuite débattre sur cette question
quel est le rôle finalement de la
commune et de l'intercommunalité dans le
développement économique est ce que
c'est eux qui doivent créer les emplois
et puis ensuite embauché les habitants
ou est ce que c'est
les entreprises qui doit venir sur le
territoire pour créer des emplois
madame du sud j'ai juste avant je pense
que sur la verrière
on a deux grands projets aussi bien sur
l'anru ou admettant que sur
sur la gendarmerie pâle sur la zac gare
vous m'entendez c'est sur la régie
municipale que juste développer mais
juste juste parce que ça implique
excusez moi c'est pas 1800 logement
acmil on s'est remis d'accord quand même
depuis depuis un moment le projet l'eau
la proposition que l'on fait c'est
d'avoir une clause d'insertion dont tous
les travaux qui sont qui seront réalisés
là comme ailleurs sur la régie de
quartier à la régie de quartier n'est
pas une régie communale
c'est une régie indépendante
l'association un fait d'habitants de
membres élus de faim de membres élus
municipaux et de membres qui est
bénévole qui ont envie de faire à
l'intérieur et s'agit là d'une régie qui
permet à qui ne concerne que les verts y
est roi
les régies de quartier ne concerne que
lui et les gens qui habitent la ville et
qui permet l'insertion par l'emploi de
gens qui sont soit en recherche d'emploi
soient éloignés de l'emploi
donc c'est finalement c'est la ville qui
est au coeur de ce mécanisme de création
d'emplois même alors on a bien compris
le jeu passe il peut aider à mettre en
place la ville d'ailleurs en cas c'est
l'association qui est indépendante dans
sa danse à 9
ok donc vous avez pris pas mal d'avancé
on va juste laissé répondre monsieur
dainville sur ce sujet vous avez une
minute à peu près de retard par rapport
aux autres outils sur l'emploi
effectivement près de 400 demandeurs
d'emploi ce qui est énorme
seize pour cent le chômage c'est
pratiquement le double que la moyenne
des yvelines donc la mairie à la fin de
doit pas rester les bras croisés
mais elle doit s'appuyer sur ce qui
existe et pour moi le lien entre la
mairie et ce qui existe c'est le rôle de
l'élu que futurs élus si nous sommes aux
responsabilités aura ce bien de cette
responsabilité de faire le lien entre la
ville et l'agglomération et toutes les
structures et dames de tu parles
d'insertion on parlait tout à l'heure
d'activité activity lagence d'inception
elle fait déjà énormément de choses on a
un projet là peut-être qu'on en parlera
peut-être de sa brique à sion
de masques à la verrière il ya il ya des
associations qui existent déjà
il ya beaucoup de choses qui existent il
faut effectivement les ramener sur la
verrière en faire profiter les verriers
roi et sur les clauses d'insertion c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'on défend mais
attention à ne pas faire rêver non plus
nos demandeurs d'emploi on a interrogé
karl olive sur le sujet qui fait
beaucoup ce type de dispositif mais
c'est une sorte de gentleman à grenade
c'est à dire à une sorte de pacte entre
l'entreprise qui fait les travaux
publics à qui on demande également
d'embaucher de former nos jeunes
donc c'est aussi ce sur quoi on envie de
travailler
vous avez 20 secondes pour conclure sur
le sujet de l'emploi jean yves les 20
secondes si vous souhaitez sinon vous
pouvez garder du temps pour la prochaine
thématique on va aborder ça sera la
dernière thématique
non non moi je suis ce que je viens de
dire c'est c'est ce rapport entre la
collectivité et les structures
d'insertion et d'emploi qu'il faut qu'il
faut développer et qu'il faut faire en
sorte qu'elles qu'elles travaillent
ensemble d'accords là le toulon je les
lis qu'on va passer à la prochaine
thématique juste on va me laisser passer
à la prochaine terme c'est parce qu'on
n'aura pas on n'aura pas le temps là
vous êtes quasiment à égalité en fait
donc c'est pour ça
oui mais alors dernière thématique c'est
au vu de l'actualité ce qui se passe au
niveau national c'est la relation entre
les forces de sécurité et les quartiers
populaires dépôt relations parfois
complexes à une certaine incompréhension
comment souhaitez-vous renouer le
dialogue entre les forces de sécurité et
des quartiers populaires et on va
commencer avec monsieur dainville vous
avez un peu de retard par rapport aux
effectivement on constate aujourd'hui à
la verrière une multiplication des
incivilités
quand on fait du terrain les habitants
nous disais je vous sors quelques
paroles d'habitants quelques verbatim
jamais ils ont vu la verrière aussi sale
il ya des des rats dans certains
quartiers des poubelles qui jauge à même
le sol la mécanique sauvage on a
l'impression que rien n'est fait pour
endiguer ce phénomène les voitures
ventouses et xix
bref il ya tout un tas d incivilités qui
pourrissent la vie du quotidien
beaucoup d'habitants s'en plaignent
qu'ils soient aux oueds les temps qu'ils
soient les partis au village ils veulent
effectivement que les règles soient
respectées pour qu'on vive bien ensemble
il faut que les règles soient respectées
que ce qui respecte ses règles n'ai pas
l'impression que ceux qui ne respectent
pas puissent agir comme ça on rend toute
impunité
donc on a tout un tas de propositions
police municipale renforcée pour à la
fois sensibiliser sur ce respect des
règles et puis sanctionner le cas
échéant
beaucoup de communes ont mis en place
une sorte de brigade verte pour faire
tout un travail avec les habitants pour
le respect des règles le voisinage et
puis surtout de propreté
et puis ils ont pensé beaucoup et on
croit beaucoup aux médiateurs sociaux
médiateur de terrain c'est vrai que
madame duthu et c'est aussi quelque
chose que je lui reproche il n'a pas
mobilisé les deux médiateurs qui était
financée par l'état donc on aurait pu
lui là depuis de nombreuses années par
deux médiateurs financé par l'état
je pense que c'est très important
d'avoir des gens de terrain qui sont
proches des habitants qui calme les
choses qui peuvent calmer les tensions
qui vaille au calme et un dernier point
qui me semble important c'est encore
sinon vous n'allez pas avoir de temps
doux et bien c'est le racontera
l'extraordinaire tous les six mois qui
réunit tous les acteurs de la sécurité à
la fois les bailleurs les associations
polices nationale et municipale pour
qu'on voie ce qui va pas et qu'on
s'adapte au terrain et à la situation
merci monsieur david nelly du sud je
vais vous je vais vous laisser répondre
par rapport au sujet des médiateurs
sociaux donc nicolas dainville vous dit
qu'ils sont qu'ils étaient financés par
l'état qu'ils étaient à disposition et
que finalement vous ne les avez pas
utilisé est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
à cela et nous dira aussi des
propositions que vous faites par rapport
au dialogue entre forces de sécurité et
quartier quartier populaire et aussi la
lutte face à l'incivilité
alors en ce qui concerne les médiateurs
monsieur david le sait ou ne le sait pas
mais on avait ton avait à en accord avec
la préfecture et là
et le pôle emploi chercher des
médiateurs pendant ça fait un an et demi
de ça il se trouve que l'accord entre la
préfecture on avait un désaccord entre
la préfecture et la bile sur le type de
médiation et les personnes médiatrice
qui pouvait le faire et ça ne s'est pas
fait mais ça ne s'est pas fait pas parce
qu'on n'a pas cherché parce qu'on n'a
pas trouvé de d'entente à ce niveau là
entre la préfecture et la ville
deuxièmement sur enfin monsieur
dainville données donne une drôle
d'image de la ville quand même je sais
pas si les habitants apprécieront
parce que oui mais j'aide invite vous
faites référence à ce qui se passe
depuis une semaine de déconfinement long
et là effectivement c'est un peu
compliqué on y reviendra plus très
bientôt mais bon je m'inscris en faux
mais en faux total sur le fait que me la
ville de la verrière serait une ville
sale et que les habitants ne se ne
tiendraient pas leurs villes qui sait
jamais s'il vous plaît vous aurez le
temps de réponse pour le temps c'est
lors de la confusion lors de sa
diffusion vous pourrez répondre à mal du
tout s'il vous plaît mais monsieur alesi
poursuivez vous avez encore aller 20
secondes de temps de parole je suis vous
pouvez conclure sur ce propos justement
nouvelle pour aller vite sur les forces
de l'ordre je pense qu'il faudrait on a
abandonné la police de proximité qui
pouvaient enfin à l'époque qu'ils
pouvaient
faire en sorte que la police nationale
rentrer en enfin qui est un dialogue
entre la police et les jeunes
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est abandonner la
police mais il n'est que sur le
répressif et oui sur la répression et ça
complique sérieusement je ne dis pas
qu'il ya des problèmes d'incivilité
mais ça complique sérieusement la lier
le le le respect et de merdj de chaque
partie merci merci madame l'étude
nicolas d'amis vous pourrez répondre au
moment de votre conclusion on va écouter
les propositions de jean il plaît à ce
sujet les deux minutes à peu près le
global mans la vie n est pas un clou on
a en effet des problèmes de comportement
d'un certain nombre de jeunes et
notamment de jeunes qui font de la main
que la moto là qui sont qui sont paix
dit il faut le dire c'est vrai et il
faut y travailler il faut faire en sorte
de régler ce souci là de ce d'autant
plus qu' il y a maintenant deux ou trois
ans je sais plus
un jeune homme s'est quand même tué en
moto sur ces choses communes et je
l'avais c'est terrible pour la famille
terrible sont faits l'un pour ce gamin
donc il ya un travail à faire c'est vrai
dans la police l'erreur et leurs
relations avec la police
je m'adapte du coup il l'a dit on avait
la police de proximité
elle a été défaite et c'est bien dommage
parce que c'était aussi un lien avec la
population et ce qui permet aussi la
discussion entre les forces de l'ordre
et la population et c'est dommageable et
donc il faut peut-être que là l'état ils
pensent nouveau et j il travaille ça
fait partie un peu du but lui du paquet
concernant le service à la population
via nos services publics
donc la voilà sur la commune on avait un
conseil local de prévention de la
sécurité de la délinquance qui a été mis
un peu en retrait qu'il faudrait
réactiver parce que ça permet le p2 que
les partenaires se rencontrent discutent
et apporte des propositions et des
solutions aux problèmes et néron à toute
collectivité
un citoyen vanille donc là et il faut il
faut travailler à ça après on a quand
même des éducateurs on a quand même une
association sur le territoire avec
lesquels il faut travailler peut-être
renforcer ses équipes et ducati pour
qu'ils aillent aussi au contact des
jeunes qui discute on a les médiateurs
de langage voulait dit tout à l'heure
qui suit c'est aussi solide donc tous
ces gens doivent apprendre à travailler
ensemble et aller vers ces jeunes et
faire en sorte que et se tourner ces
jeunes vers les structures qui pourront
les aider à se sortir de là où ils sont
dans leur vie merci jean ridley donc
vous êtes quasiment en même temps parole
en 9 minutes 30 pour même du tunnel
nicolas david et 9 minutes 39 pour
jean-yves blé vous allez avoir une
minute pour conclure vous pouvez
conclure sur un élément qui a été
abordée ou pas pendant ce débat ou
répondre par rapport à la question de la
sécurité et je vais commencer avec vous
monsieur dainville m'écouter dimanche 28
juin
c'est un moment essentiel pour la vie de
notre commune soit on continue avec
madame du tulle et son bilan que
beaucoup d'habitants puisque 60% d'entre
eux ne se sont pas prononcés
soit il ya une opportunité historique
d'apporter du sang neuf jeux mobilité
les partenaires c'est essentiel pour
faire avancer des projets ambitieux pour
l'emploi pour la sécurité pour la
qualité de vie et donc je pense que
c'est un moment très important pour
apporter une nouvelle vision nouvelle
dynamique un peu d'air frais et surtout
mettre fin un système qui pour l'instant
iso notre commune avec beaucoup
d'opacité
voilà et une gestion qui doit être à mon
avis plus rigoureuse un point qu'on n'a
pas évoqué mais c'est un poids aussi
essentiel il faut qu'on ait la meilleure
gestion possible pour avoir la meilleure
la verrière possible jean yves blais
conclusion moi je faisais la tête d'une
équipe diverse d'une vraie volonté de
terre veut rentrer notre ville dans ce
21e siècle est de faire en sorte qu' un
certain nombre de choses évoluent
notamment concernant l'urbanisme parce
que je pense que tout est lié
le bien vivre ensemble c'est aussi le
bien être chez soi et donc là il ya un
travail important a amené notre équipe
elle est prête à ça elle ya travaillé
on s'est appuyé aussi sur ce que nous
ont dit les habitants eux nous nous
avons sentiment qu'au sortir de ce
premier tour ça n'aurait plaît pas ce
que nous avons entendu lors de nos de
nos porte à porte lors de nos échanges
lors de nos temps de travaux avait avec
avec ces derniers j'espère moi que le
vote fut meilleur monsieur gré ils ont
un pardon bas la tendance s'inverse et
que ça la terre si je sais je me suis
blessé
merci monsieur de faire madame cette
madame tutu votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît oui monsieur t'invite fait
beaucoup d'incantations mais de ne pas
beaucoup de preuves de ce qu'il avance
cet hommage là je ne dit que ça enfin je
veux dire les élections il faut que les
habitants les derrière moi nous ont mis
en tête à la fin du premier tour
n'en déplaise à monsieur dainville on a
40% des voix
on est tout à fait légitime à continuer
ce combat je crois que les gens vont
devoir choisir entre une gestion humaine
sociale de gauche et une gestion à la
macro
voilà simplement walid parce que j'ai
pas beaucoup de temps mais le choix
s'est fait comme ça
donc moi j'en appelle aux habitants pour
continuer à faire ensemble une
citoyenneté dans la ville de construire
ensemble
mais comme on a fait jeu
merci merci madame duthu et merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
un débat que vous pourrez revoir en
replay sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme le scrutin donc le 28 juin
prochain
merci et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]